thank you have to kill an empire let's
tear that stretch so it oh yes and I've
decided you will yes go now you'll gain
unrestricted access to the kitchen here
all it once meet has been now go my
friend go and fulfill your destiny
service okay salad teeth [ __ ]
yeah look at it [ __ ] looks like you're
new in town right there okay walking up
here walking up here I can't matches I
can't have to be careful wait I know you
stop right there what's this now order
of His Eminence by Audra the gourmet i
I'm sorry I didn't realize we had no
idea who to expect understand but we
don't let me keep you proceed to the
kitchen straight away yo guys betcha
chef has been eagerly awaiting your
arrival
iana will be overjoyed to me that's
dirty hell I like [ __ ] how do I lack
[ __ ] psychopath okay not another
delivery I the gourmet that is far away
when I heard the gourmet was being
brought in to cook for the Emperor I
could hardly believe it it's just it's
just well during orch oh oh actually
you're not wearing a chef's hat I mean
there's one right over there on the
shelf you can't very well cope without
it ok I think I have a chef's hat oh
just look at you know yes but of course
the Emperor but the cook the base broth
is already boiled we can get started
right now so which ingredients should I
add next carrots really ok what next of
course all right what next in really oh
ok now what
mmm corker sorry I didn't mean to away
there we go my heart is like worker me I
have to say this too seems done I had
anything else and we may dilute the
distinct flavor Oh what is this some
kind of herb are you sure I'm all right
then and if I may say so I'll carry the
stewpot and lead the way up to the
dining room I'm sure the Emperor and his
guests are dying to make you a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm a shipper you know it's going
to love them not oh this is me here take
these cash
that's a good [ __ ] here let's online if
I go in a second towel loves his friends
mmm taste a chef's hat not back in
that's it let me just take all this mate
and they love cheese in this place
that's [ __ ] a okay what are going to
go Oh titties at the vibe come on grab
that status that was a headache
there's a today's batch know that Bernie
called me hot tempered here we are God's
I'm nervous life will go in here just a
moment please I'll serve you just stand
there and be amazing some of your
commander quatrain your assassination
yes an unfortunate turn of events that
button home bae incident is such and all
I have been assured that the fault was
with the man's son alone truth is we are
a million voices when I've loved your
story Audra can be useful 21 now that's
beneficial as I'm sure the Potala man
you seek aha delire we are honored yet i
present to you great well Kagome ah the
Potala money seek so delicious my
friends as Emperor I of course reserves
the right health first taste ok Oh
marvelous just delicious it is
everything I had hoped it would be it
died I think something's wrong I I
prefer a good roast duck but you're
gonna do hey Dad oh man I'm gonna
propose to the Emperor get them you know
no you don't understand this there's
been some kind of mistake right fine i
just say you may get back I didn't say
in that good take out those routes pitch
that is
check it out of here hey watch what you
do something
we're Shadowman
that man was by far the most
insufferable decoy the emperor has ever
employed I'm glad he's dead onion
happiness you killed you assassins of
the Dark Brotherhood just made an
attempt on the Emperor's life would have
succeeded had it been the real surprise
so was I when a member of your family
Anthony was a flag we worked out a deal
an exchange I get you and the Dark
Brotherhood gets the continuous existed
but you know what I've changed my mind
how about this I kill you and put your
each and every one of your miserable
little French their sanctuary teams
what's in the store but now that's what
I think is it sealed you killed my son
all of you and now you'll pay the price
Taylor let's count it here there's
nothing left to bury
[ __ ] socialist [ __ ] it we're stuck
you're in the way and the [ __ ] lay
here doc come this way
by order of the yard I come out of the
water the yard stop right there hygienic
chasez the approach doesn't ship right
here Rizzoli nothing but [ __ ] you didn't
hear this time the sanctuary not a
[ __ ] waste oh if your dog out there
always is all stay on the lookout you
can know slain while you're here outside
okay like that okay oh okay